guys. So in this lecture, we're going to learn about the 930 AM trading
strategy. Bear in mind, it works the best with indices. For example,
mass 100 SMP 500. Okay, it does work with forex as well. But I would
recommend that you stick to indices with this trading strategy. Okay. So first
of all, you want to change your time zone to New York. Okay. And then you
want to trade. You can only trade between 930 AM till 1159 AM New
York time. Okay. So this is your window period. Okay, you can only
trade within these hours. So this is the very first rule of the
trading strategy. Okay. The second rule is you want to identify some sort of
liquidity. Okay. So you want to identify some sort of liquidity between these
hours. Okay. And or you can start looking for some sort of liquidity at 925 AM.
Okay. You can take trades after 930. Okay. So let's say if okay, I'm going to
explain it later. But you want the rule number two is you want to identify some
sort of liquidity. Okay. And the rule number three is you want you want to
wait for price to sweep that liquidity. Okay. So you want to wait for price to
take out the liquidity. Okay. That you have identified. Once you're once the
price. Oh man. Once the price sweeps out the liquidity, you want to wait for you
then wait for market structure shift. Okay. Once price takes out the liquidity,
then you then wait for market structure shift. And you now there are two ways to
enter. Okay. You can either take the entry from the first fair value gap. Or you
take your entry from the extreme fair value gap. So what I mean by that is let's
say this is liquidity, right? Before. So this is the 930 open, right? This is
where let's say, for example, okay, the 930 time starts from here. And you have
this liquidity zone equal highs, you know, day off the high, it could be any sort
of liquidity. Okay. So it could be equal highs. It could be a major swing high or
a swing low. It could be a daily high daily low or previous day high previous
day low. It could be a weekly high a weekly low. So any sort of liquidity. Okay.
And then you wait for price to sweep the liquidity. Okay. And on the once the
price sweeps the liquidity or actually when you spot the liquidity, you want to
go down to the one minute time frame. So you are looking for liquidity on a 15
minute timeframe. Okay, bear, keep this in mind. You have to look for liquidity on a
15 minute timeframe, 15. Okay. And once you have spotted the liquidity and the 930
starts, you go to the one minute timeframe, you wait for price to sweep up the
liquidity. And then on the one minute timeframe, this is how the price is
going to look like, right? Price sweeps the liquidity. And then you wait for
market structure shift. So this right here is a market structure shift. As you
can see, now, before the price breaks this structure, there would be some fair
value gap here, here and the extreme one here. So you can either take your entry
from the very first fair value gap. Okay. But you're gonna keep your stop
loss up there. So and there's another option that is your take your entry from
the extreme fair value gap. Now, what would happen with this is if you take
your entry from the extreme fair value gap, you're gonna get a higher risk to
reward trade. Okay. But if you take your entry from, let's say the very first
fair value gap, you're gonna have a bigger stop loss. But you're not gonna miss a
trade. Okay. So sometimes if you have if you have your entry at the very extreme
fair value gap, you're gonna miss out the trade. So I would say that straight
with the extreme fair value gap, because you know, it's okay to sometimes miss
the trade, as long as you're getting the trades with big risk reward trades, and
it's gonna cover up the missed trades, if that makes sense. So here's the thing.
When the price sweeps the liquidity, you want to wait for market structure shift,
and then you enter at the fair value gap, and you target, you know, some sort of
fair value gap here, or I go by this rule, when I take my entry and I have my
stop loss, I go for minimum risk to reward three, and I can go for maximum
five risk reward. This is all I go for. Okay. I do not chase big risk reward
trades, because, you know, there's so much going on the world right now, and I do
not want to hold my trades for a longer duration. So yes, we have then you can
either take the entry from the first failure gap, or you could take your entry
from the extreme failure gap. So I'm gonna give you guys some examples, and it's
gonna be crystal clear to you guys.